we're going to be talking about the
federal mass mandate for a little while
longer public transportation federal
masks the mandate has been extended
passengers on planes trains and other
forms of transportation will be required
to wear face coverings for at least two
more weeks that's through may 3rd the
measure was originally set to expire on
monday errol barnett is at reagan
national airport just outside of
washington d.c errol good morning what's
the thinking here
hey there good morning tony look this
decision comes despite fierce and
ongoing resistance from the airlines the
travel industry and some republican
lawmakers as well but it also means that
air travelers are now experiencing two
full years of having a mask up while
traveling now the spread of the recent
ba2 sub-variant of omicron is why the
cdc says this extension is needed
announcing in a statement that the move
gives them time to assess the potential
impact the rise of cases has on severe
disease including hospitalizations and
debts now the spread of the sub-variant
has caused an uptick in reported cases
since early april driving outbreaks in
the northeast and parts of florida as
we've been reporting it now makes up
more than 85 percent of all u.s covert
infections and this is now the fifth
extension and there are lawsuits filed
in mostly republican-led states seeking
to overturn the federal mass requirement
altogether but we cannot exclude the
american public here a recent harris
poll in late march and early april found
60 of respondents are okay and support
an extension of the mandate and when we
came here to reagan national yesterday
speaking with travellers they agree so
despite that ongoing resistance most
americans are okay with masking up at
least for the moment these next few
weeks until we know more about this
sub-variant vlad
all right harold thank you very much